the tiber family have maintained their
reputation for centuries as what can
only be called the best eldians
which is simply put the only eldians who
really get along with marlins
they've staked their name on the main
continent as a reputable and respectable
family of honorable marlians
and with the physical reveal of the
warhammer titan in the recent episode
we've essentially moved past any
possible spoilers for anime only
watchers
so i felt that this was a fitting time
to explore the history of the tiber
family and the warhammer titan
which has presumably been their property
ever since the great titan war
which is of course where we'll begin
but first if you enjoy attack on titan
anime or manga make sure to hit that
subscribe button
would be a huge help to the growing
channel enjoy the video
when carl fritz became king and thus the
owner of the founding titan
he formulated a plan to exile the
aldians out of his own guilt for what
they've historically done to the marlins
you know the whole massacre mass
genocide thing
that whole deal and for this plan he
worked with the tiber family who are of
course
other aliens historically there were
nine eldian houses eight of which were
subservient to the fritz family who of
course carried the founding titan
and they fought for years on end over
control over the other eight titan
powers
and though it's never explicitly
confirmed it's assumed that the tiber
family was one of them
and at this point they were already
owners of the warhammer titan
when they first got it and howe is never
explored
as part of the plan king fritz abandoned
the main continent and moved to paradise
island
so he could create his paradise i guess
an island where no one knew of this
terrible history and could live in peace
etc it's all something we know pretty
well by this point so i'm not going to
go really in depth into king fritz and
the walls and so the king's absence on
the main continent left the elding
families in shambles
without the central power of the founder
to guide them
and thus the tiber family in association
with king fritz presented hilos
the marlian hero who would help to
destroy the eldian empire
helos was of course created by the
tigers and fritz
but he helped to guide the marlians into
the great titan war and overthrow the
aldians
the tibers were the first to join the
marlins in the fight
because of course they helped plan it
and the marlians obtained seven of the
nine titan shifters
all of that is essentially the short
history of the great titan war
all of which was essentially
orchestrated by king fritz and the
tibers
the tiber family was praised and offered
high nobility within the new marlin
empire for their actions during the war
much higher status than the typical
honorary marlin that we see nowadays
they lived in mansions and estates in
what is close to isolation
but despite their good friendship with
the marlians never allowed them to use
the warhammer titan that the family
owned for any more fights throughout
history
similar to how the founding titan was
passed through the generations of the
fritz family
the warhammer titan was passed through
the generations of the tigers
perhaps the reason that they never
allowed the marlins to use the warhammer
titan for fights
was in a way to honor king fritz's
desire of peace
and their regret over the existence of
titans in general
or it's because at the end of the day
they are aldians
and giving their powers to the marlins
is just not something they want to do
and this could very well be the case
considering that in their isolation
the tiber family was actually slowly
improving the reputation of eldians and
subjects of emir on the main continent
i mean i guess it's the least they could
do after betraying the rest of the
aldians with king fritz in the great war
and so they've historically played the
role of the middle ground the mediator
between the aldeans and the marlians
seeing as they sided with king fritz and
then sided with the marlians
essentially throughout history they've
just allied themselves with who was in
power
but they have not forgotten their elding
origins nor dedication to the peace that
king fritz sought for the world and the
subjects of ymir
the name of the current holder of the
warhammer titan willie tiber's sister
was never actually stated in the manga
but the anime has dubbed her as lara
tiber in the recent transition screen we
see here i'm not sure whether we should
consider this as canon but i'll just
keep going forward calling her lara from
here
the warhammer titan's main power is the
ability to create any structure it
desires from hardened titan flesh
this primarily takes the form of weapons
ranging from close combat such as a
a warhammer to ranged weapons like
crossbows
but it can essentially be anything we
saw during her fight with aaron in
episode 6 how lara created dozens of
spikes from the ground to stab aaron and
a huge pillar to impale him
so the hardened flesh itself can vary in
flexibility and shape
the titan can also be remotely operated
a trait we've never seen in any other
titan shifter before
this eliminates the weakness of the nape
that all other titans carry
and so even if the user is found they're
contained within the hardened crystal
form that we've only seen the female
titan used before
and so the crystal is connected to the
body by a long cable of this hardened
flesh
and because the user can create anything
out of its flesh it can also regenerate
a whole new warhammer titan on the cord
even if it's severed
and the crystal as we know is nearly
impossible to pierce
nearly impossible make note of that
and so the combination of remote
operation and the ability to make any
weapon it desires makes the warhammer
titan what is likely the titan shifter
best suited for combat
after beating both reiner and annie in
hand-to-hand combat aaron had
essentially cemented himself as the best
titan fighter up to this point
i mean i would hope the attack titan
would be the best but
but without the element of surprise
against the warhammer titan in this
episode
as well as assistance from mikasa this
battle between them would have probably
gone a lot worse for aaron
aaron from what we know can't break the
hardened crystal
otherwise the islanders would have
gotten annie out of hers by now wouldn't
they
and so even if he were to try and fight
the warhammer one-on-one even if he
could beat her in a fight
he wouldn't be able to finish her off
because he couldn't get through the
crystal
it would either end in a loss for aaron
or a stalemate
and so it's really surprising that the
marlins never used the warhammer titan
for themselves throughout history
i mean considering the warhammer titans
powers they probably did repeatedly
request for its abilities from the
tibers
but i suppose out of respect for the
tibers and historical presidents they
didn't go too far in trying to use it
for themselves
i mean marlians have shown disrespect to
just about all aliens we've seen except
the tigers
so it's safe to assume that they're an
entirely different level than any kind
of elding we've seen before
and so that's all for the tibers and the
warhammer titan as of season 4
episode 6 the battle isn't done yet but
let me tell you guys
anyone who's anime only you should be
really hyped for the next couple
episodes
this battle overall is awesome and has
one of the most badass moments i've read
in manga before
definitely look forward to it as always
this has been the anime culture corner i
hope you enjoyed the video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses